[Música]
estamos en comunicación con enrique
público antro antropólogo social y
etnólogo profesor asociado en el
departamento de ciencias de las
religiones de la universidad de quebec
en montreal y vamos a hablar de algo que
es muy navideño de algo que no se hace
siempre sentirnos ya en ambiente
las fiestas de diciembre que tal enrique
pico como nueva
muy bien paloma muchas gracias por
invitación
muchas gracias por aceptarla enrique
comencemos hablando usted y su
especialidad es la historia
la idea antropología social como
decíamos pero en este caso vamos a
hablar de villancicos porque usted tiene
una especialidad o un conocimiento bien
particular sobre la historia de los
villancicos en américa latina' háblenos
un poco de forma general porque claro
que me imagino que depende de cada país
que depende de cada década villancico en
tanto como tal su historia pero de forma
general que podríamos decir sobre esta
llegada de los villancicos américa
latina'
si este lo he dicho es un tema bastante
complejo pero se puede resumir en esta
palabra que son los villancicos porque
es una música que resume este espíritu
de navidad y es una historia que nos
conecta en realidad con el mundo
hispano ya que el villancico llegó a
américa latina o américa a través de la
conquista y es una historia que sé
que hunde sus raíces en el medioevo el
renacimiento en la época en que este
género comienza a tomar cuerpo comienza
a ser adaptado y a ser incluido e
incorporado a partir de la cultura
popular en las celebraciones de navidad
como investigador antropólogo yo me
interesó siempre a la música como la
manera de llegar a entender una sociedad
en su proceso básicamente yo he
estudiado la música religiosa que llega
con la conquista se implante en américa
y que se diversifica y adopta diferentes
matices uno de los tipos de música que
ha pasado por este proceso es
precisamente el de francisco pero no es
el único
me preguntaba enrique si había alguna
característica digamos que defina al
vidente o latinoamericano es decir
imagino que son las influencias
indígenas de la que la combinación
digamos de de sonidos de ritmos incluso
de temáticas sonoras y musicales
indígenas y con respecto a las mezclas
con las españolas pero hay algo que
digamos podemos decir que define el
villancico latinoamericano
por supuesto y esto es lo que marca la
diferencia con el villancico español
villancico viene desde el término
villanos que era el labriego el
habitante de los del campo que se
diferenciaba de los hidalgos no había
una temática popular ya antes del
comienzo en américa cuando llega el
villancico el villancico es incorporado
como una música ligada a los pelos a los
que hay que impartir la
doctrina cristiana estamos hablando de
pueblos indígenas y también pueblos de
afrodescendientes
es de esta manera que el villancico va a
ser
difundido en base a la cultura local es
decir la música indígena por ejemplo los
textos en base a las lenguas indígenas
por ejemplo tenemos villancicos en
náhuatl
centroamérica en los andes' tenemos
villancicos en quechua que todavía son
práctica 2 pero también tenemos los
villancicos que eran de desarrollados en
el ámbito de los de las poblaciones de
origen africano incluso este villancico
llegó a ser un género
un género aparte pues se le llamaba
negrillo negrilla o también
guineo entonces esa es la riqueza del
villancico en américa latina que adopta
estos matices y la música también va a
ser enriquecido con elementos distintos
por ejemplo el uso de percusiones ellis
el uso de silbatos además del uso de los
instrumentos europeos pero ya adaptados
a la realidad latinoamericana
por ejemplo el arpa y el violín que se
difunden pues en todo el territorio y
las poblaciones este locales las van a
adoptar como sueños
algo que me llamaría la atención y que
me gustaría que usted nos dijera que si
sucede también en la música en los
villancicos en particular algo que
sucedió por ejemplo en la arquitectura
en américa por ejemplo por lo menos en
mexico supongo que habrá sido algo que
se practicó en otras regiones de las
américas pero por lo menos en méxico
cuando se comenzaron a construir las
ingles en los edificios de las iglesias
de los españoles cuando se establecieron
allí y cuando había todo el proceso de
la evangelización en entre las
poblaciones indígenas
los indígenas mismos guardaban escondían
dentro de la estructura de las iglesias
algunos de los símbolos más
representativos de sus propias creencias
entonces me pregunto si habrá elementos
así escondidos que fueron mantenidos en
los básicos bueno está de las las
músicas que surgieron con la llegada de
los españoles hice digamos que sé
se auto complementaron vaya
por supuesto y el punto es bastante
válido ya que la arquitectura el arte y
otro tipo de manifestaciones
no escritas y puede usarse el término
como la música transmite una forma de
ver el mundo y las poblaciones indígenas
tuvieron bastante que decir a través de
estas expresiones efectivamente en la
música es muy interesante y el
villancico ilustra esto y es uno de los
puntos que voy a tratar el día de mañana
en la conferencia organizada por la
misión de américa y es que el villancico
adopta
formas musicales netamente indígenas que
va a incorporar en su estructura de esta
manera da la posibilidad a que formas
musicales de origen prehispánico
alcancen vigencia y se proyecten en el
tiempo y gracias a ello podemos apreciar
los en la actualidad por tomar un
ejemplo solamente el caso de la casa la
casa era una danza prehispánica de los
cronistas la describe muy bien
ocasiones celebratorias la época de los
incas que consistía en
el desplazamiento coreografiado de los
participantes para desplegar figuras en
espacios abiertos y después
desplazándose al mismo tiempo este tipo
de danza en la época colonial va pues
ser filtrada y absorbida por la cultura
popular ya esté urbana y le va a dar un
nuevo impulso
uno de estos impulsos es el villancico y
es por eso que hoy día todavía podemos
encontrar aunque no con ese nombre pero
sí
distinguir casas que se podían bailar
justamente en el contexto de los
festejos navideños como parte de los
autos sacramentales que es decir los
16-17 fueron practicados en los andes
muy interesante enrique pico qué tan
difícil es para usted hacer su
investigación que tiene toda su digamos
que su origen o su fundamento digamos se
encuentra en américa latina hacer ese
tipo de investigación desde canadá
bueno es cierto debo admitir que hace
bastante tiempo que no he vuelto a
tratar estos temas son es un tema que
había abordado cuando hacía mi tesis
doctoral porque mi trabajo entonces era
estuvo volcado a la música religiosa
este y al mestizaje musical después
bueno cambié un poco el giro me interesé
en otro tipo de música pero el interés
persiste y lo que yo hago es tratar de
ver a través de redes sociales qué está
pasando como está evolucionando el este
tipo de música y qué información puedo
tener así que en base a eso me doy trata
de actualizar un poco lo que ya había
constatado hace ya varios años en él
sobre el terreno si se puede decir
muy bien mi interés es muy interesante
en realidad me imagino que debe tener
desafíos el estar lejos cuando algunos
destrozos temas de investigación están
están a la distancia pero tiene también
algunas digamos me imagino cosas
positivas también por supuesto uno
cuando está fuera del contexto inmediato
le da alcanza a tener una apreciación
distinta el panorama se abre y puede ver
elementos o detalles que no son
evidentes cuando uno está cerca a los
hechos esto me pasa y yo saco partido de
estadista de esta distancia obligada
aunque bueno yo voy al perú cada año no
por este temporadas muy largas pero
trato siempre de estar seguir en
contacto dado dadá las posibilidades
dada la situación actual que estamos
viviendo es un poco complicado por
supuesto
enrique pil que usted es antropólogo
social y etnólogo profesora asociado en
el departamento de ciencias de las
religiones de la universidad de que
venga aquí en montreal y estará
presentando este viernes 11 de diciembre
a las 17 horas una conferencia que lleva
por título justamente historia de los
villancicos en américa latina'
muchísimas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros de información sobre la
conferencia la incluiremos en nuestro
sitio internet también gracias
gracias a ustedes
[Música]